My name is Josh Weston.
I got into bladesmithing
from Spartacus.
Something inside me lit on
fire, and I had to make swords.
I'm Jason Redick.
I started making blades when I
was a kid with my grandfather.
I'm 100% self-taught.
[soft music]
Jason.
Josh.
Congratulations, you've
made it to the final round.
When you came here
we asked you to forge
a blade in your signature style
using our tools and our forges.
Now we're sending
you home to create
an iconic blade from history--
[dramatic music]
--the kukri.
Hell, yes.
[dramatic music]
WIL WILLIS
(VOICEOVER): The kukri
is a blade issued to Nepalese
soldiers, known as the Gurkhas.
During the Anglo-Nepalese war
in the early 19th century,
the kukri became renowned
in the Western world for its
versatility on the battlefield.
The kukri's unique curved
design, and angle of the blade,
gives it the ability to slice
and chop simultaneously.
The Gurkha soldiers were said
to be so skilled with kukri
that it acted as an
extension of their arm.
Today, the kukri is far
more visible worldwide,
seen in films like "Resident
Evil Extinction," and
"Big Trouble in Little China."
It must be a fully
functioning, authentic version
of that deadly weapon.
I'm really nervous
because I know literally
nothing about this blade.
You will have five days
to complete this challenge.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
[music playing]
Let's crank the heat.
[blade sharpening]
Whoa!
I am very, very happy.
Me likey.
JOSH WESTON: The mid-bar
is welded together.
I've drawn out a
new piece of steel.
I'm forge welding them together.
There's a lot of
forging left to be done.
I am doing my damnedest
to win this thing.
I've got to try to
punch this thing.
It's going to be difficult
to get an even temperature.
JOSH WESTON (VOICEOVER): The
quench is the most critical
part of the sword build.
All right.
Who's ready?
JOSH WESTON: This is it.
If this blade doesn't
survive the quench, I'm sunk.
There's just no
coming back from it.
Three, two, one.
JOSH WESTON: I'm
finding absolutely
nothing wrong with this blade.
Everything is exactly
as it should be.
I have a blade!
Whoa, ha, whoa!
[music playing]
JASON REDICK: Now that I'm back
home, I feel much more at ease.
I'm used to my equipment.
I've got a wonderful family.
And if I could
win this, it would
mean all the support
that my family has
given me over the years is--
you know, they've
been correct to do it.
This is a lot larger of a
kukri than I've made before.
So it's going to be a little
bit more forging and stuff
than what I'm used to.
Yeah.
I wish the head was
a little bit wider.
I think it'll be all right.
Got the blade shaped
up the way I wanted.
The blade seems
nice and straight.
I'm leaving it to cool now.
We're good, and I
can heat treat it.
[music playing]
Got to be real careful
not to move it.
Just let this thing sit
still inside the oil,
and completely cool down.
At this point I hope I got
time to get everything done.
[sharpening]
JASON REDICK: All right.
[upbeat music]
JOSH WESTON: That's good.
[slow music]
Jason, Josh, welcome back.
Many battles Gurkha
soldiers have fought
were defending forts,
just like this one.
So we thought it would
be an ideal place
to test your kukris.
We will now put
both of your weapons
through a series of tests.
First up, the strength test.
Doug.
DOUG: Bladesmiths, Kukris
were multipurpose knives
as well as weapons of war.
It was also used commonly to
clear the fields of Nepal,
as well as chop wood.
To test the strength
of your kukri,
I will cut through
these sugar canes.
Jason, you're up.
You ready?
I'm ready.
I'm getting nervous, because
it's all out of my hands now.
[upbeat music]
Well, Jason.
This is a beast.
Thank you.
I do not see any indentations
in your blade, at all.
So it cut nicely.
But the handle construction
is very hard to hold
onto because it's very smooth.
Yeah.
DOUG: But, once
again, it did its job.
Good job.
Thank you.
Josh, you're up.
You're ready?
I'm ready.
Is this thing even going
to hold up and come
out in one piece at the end?
I have no idea.
[upbeat music]
Well, Josh, I don't
see any indentations
on your edge over here.
I like the balance.
Your handle is nice and
comfortable around the hand.
I was able to maintain
control of it.
And the edge is sharp enough to
cut through these sugar canes.
Good job.
JOSH WESTON: I think coming
out of the sugar cane test--
we're at a tie right now.
All right, gentlemen,
next up is the kill test.
The kukri is a powerful
weapon in combat--
so much so that in 1814,
22,000 British soldiers
went up against 600 Gurkhas,
armed with the kukri.
The British suffered
massive losses
and the Gurkhas
never surrendered.
Thus began the legend and
reputation of the kukri.
To test of lethality and
function of your blade,
I will take your
kukri and I will
slash through these carcasses.
[dramatic beats]
DOUG: Jason, you're up.
All right.
Let's go.
My heart's beating.
Any time you cut bone, it's
very, very hard on the blade.
If you're going to get a chip
or something in your blade,
it's going to happen when
you cut through bone.
[dramatic music]
Well, Jason, the beast
over here, it cuts.
Just the way it sliced
through this time,
I felt the nice
curve in your design.
This, sir, will kill.
Thank you.
Josh, you're up.
You ready?
Let's do it.
I'm half excited and
half [bleep] my pants.
[dramtic music]
Well, Josh, your blade didn't
slash all the way through
the carcasses, but it did cut.
And those kinds
of cuts will kill.
WIL WILLIS: Jason, Josh,
you were given five
days at your home
forge to design
and fabricate signature kukris.
You've both done
a fantastic job.
This was a very
difficult decision,
but there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion.
[dramatic sound effect]
WIL WILLIS: Jason,
congratulations.
Josh, unfortunately, you
did not make the cut.
Josh, when I saw your
blade in the strength test,
the way it performed, I
expected it to continue
performing that way.
And your edge retention
didn't hold up.
So that's why I
have to let you go.
WIL WILLIS: Josh, please
surrender your weapon.
I am disappointed,
but what I've
learned from this
experience is invaluable.
And even though I didn't walk
away with 10 grand today,
I don't feel like a loser.
So that's a really nice
relief at the end of it.
Jason, congratulations,
you are the "Forged in Fire"
champion, which comes
with a $10,000 check.
Yes.
I just won 10 grand.
Oh, god, am I--
I'm so happy right
now I can barely talk.
Man, you got a beast there.
[chuckles]
That thing-- you get that
in motion, that's going
to keep going and going.
JASON REDICK: Oh, yeah.
That edge great.
Thank you.
I came here to
prove that I'm doing
the right thing with my life.
And I feel like I've
accomplished all that.
I'll be bragging about this
for a long time to come.
[dramatic music]